vrai que là il ya eu un vent de panique
qui souffle sur la france c'est parti de
bordeaux dû dénoncer pour l'ensemble du
pays
l'urgence en france est en prison
clairement oui l'hôpital public est en
difficulté et évidemment les services
d'urgence qui sont confrontés à
l'arrivée
imprévue de patients sont en difficulté
également
donc on espère bien sûr que l'on va
pouvoir franchir les étapes qui viennent
avec sérénité mais on a besoin de plus
d'effectifs de plus de moyens et surtout
de revoir l'organisation hospitalière
pas ce qu'est ce qui est étonnant c'est
qu'on est né parce que vides enfin on
espère et posco vide on n'a parlé que de
ça pendant des mois voire des années en
fait rien n'a changé vous êtes en fait
responsable du service d'urgence de
l'hôpital lariboisière vraiment c'est la
crise absolue c'est la crise absolue il
faut voir que à l'échelon national c'est
la crise il faut voir que les hôpitaux
qui sont en difficulté comme ce bordeaux
orléans sont pas des petits hôpitaux
sont des gros hôpitaux des hôpitaux
référence à plérin plus réputé des chu
donc c'est vraiment pas des petites
structures donc quand une grosse
structure comme assez haché ou des chr
comme orléans sont en difficulté c'est
un nombre important de patients qui sont
qui sont en difficulté jeudi pour les
patients parce qu'on est là pour les
patients et du coup c'est l'accès aux
soins qui est vraiment limité cette
cette situation qu'on voit temps à
bordeaux ou à orléans c'est faire du
triage extrêmement dangereux parce que
c'est pénalisant pour les patients avec
un retard de prise en charge pour
l'espionner l'accord que là-bas à
bordeaux c'est le samu par téléphone qui
dit si ou non oui on peut se rendre aux
urgences moi je dirais pas le cas des
nations du snu samu on reste chez soi
c'est ça et ils devraient oui mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait plaisant que ça
c'est ceara tic c'est mes samia des abus
aussi des gens qui téléphonent leur nez
pour ça
la bobologie dont vous parlez voilà ses
caisses et quelques personnes quelques
cas qui me réfère à léo d'urgence plutôt
que d'aller de soi y est mais là on
parle de gens qui sont vivants en
situation de stress de danger et dans
les morts comme une conne comme on peut
faire la messe et c'est ça le problème
qu sur lequel on alerte parce qu'il faut
comme aig comprendre que la situation
est unique de la manière dont ça se
présente bien sûr tous les ans on alerte
un petit peu sur les fermetures de l'île
fermetures d'hôpitaux les difficultés
liées aux halles était là la situation
elle est unique et je pense aussi à
l'effet post co vide qui fait que le
manque d'infirmières le manque
d'effectif houleux on le sait le désert
un petit peu actuellement de l'accès aux
soins et malheureusement ça met en
difficulté pour des pour des situations
urgentes un infarctus par exemple il ya
du retard à la prise en charge s'il peut
pas avoir accès aux soins quel est le
délai
souhaitable ou idéal dans le cas d'une
prise en charge d'un avenant à la
faculté que précéder minutes ah non
c'est vrai c'est moins que ça va en
faire moins que ça je dirais que c'est
moi que ça pour là pour appeler pour la
douleur mais aurait ainsi que les gens
appellent mais la recommandation est
fait qu'on arrive dans l'eure dans
l'eure dans leurs ennemis pour arriver
au plus tôt mais c'est moins de trois
heures pour pouvoir accéder à un plateau
de coronarographie connais pas on n'est
pas en arrêt cardiaque là on est en haut
on risque d'arrêt cardiaque
après d'accord quel moment d'un
infarctus à n'importe quel moment
l'arrêt cardiaque ces anneaux c'est un
autre problème notre problème sur lequel
les minutes comptent pour un arrêt
cardiaque ces six minutes là on arrive à
l'été voilà les gens partent en vacances
c'est des accidents de voiture qu'ils
ont des motos possédant deux balades sur
la plage des noyades donc là on dit ça
fait encore plus compliqué on a un petit
un petit document avons montré en a pas
juste après des urgentistes marseillais
qui travaillent à effectif réduit de
moitié et inquiet pour l'été pour les
deux mois à venir et à paris c'est un
hôpital gériatrique qui met la clé sous
la porte le temps des vacances
des services hospitaliers au bord de la
rupture partout en france à la veille de
l'été des médecins épuisé par la crise
sanitaire ont fini par jeter l'épongé et
pour la première fois dans ce grand chu
marseillais impossible de remplir le
planning de l'été au ministère de la
santé on reconnaît des difficultés
d'organisation dans les hôpitaux alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et ce qu'on
va faire comme pour les serveurs on va
faire appel à des docteurs étrangers
alors ça c'est une bonne question les
médecins étrangers postule et on ya des
candidats les candidatures ce que la
france est quand même un pays attractif
pour les pour les médecins ont fait de
la bonne médecine et on a des bons
médecins étrangers qui peuvent
travailler donc faut ouvrir un petit peu
7,7 cette vanne parce que
malheureusement il faut quand même
regret que 30% des hôpitaux en france
assez bien avant fonctionner avec des
médecins étrangers à diplôme étranger
donc il faut quand même reconnaître
qu'on a une médecine attractive le
problème que vous soulevez c'est surtout
celui de l'intérim où malheureusement et
c'est la situation qu'on voit pour l'été
c'est que même la totalité des agences
d'intérim ne pourrons pas arriver à
remplir ces postes-là qui sont vacants
en été parce que compte tenu de la
formation médecin infirmière urgentiste
c'est des mois et des années bien
évidemment là aujourd'hui si on réagit
le bénéfice se sera pas maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait vous avez raison il
ya un problème chronique la wii qui est
lié au numerus clausus pour les médecins
et à l'attractivité de la profession
pour les paramédicaux et puis un
problème immédiat c'est à dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont fait 15 à 20 %
des lits hospitaliers sont fermés faute
de personnel et malheureusement pour
traiter le manque de personnel on ferme
davantage de lits donc la pression sur
les personnels qui sont qui continue à
travailler augmente et de fait plutôt
que de rester définissent pas reparti
aussi et donc en fait on est dans un
cercle vicieux où le problème continue
de s'aggraver donc en fait c'est une
fois de plus les hôpitaux privés à qui
on peut se tourner seulement ceux qui
ont les moyens qui vont pouvoir faire
soyez
pas si c'est voulu si c'est une
stratégie voulue mais non annoncés ou si
malheureusement c'est la situation que
l'on voudrait éviter mais deux fait
effectivement on est en train de
développer un système à double brive et
s
l'hôpital public qui ne va s'occuper que
des personnes qui n'ont pas les moyens
ou entre guillemets quant à
l'intéressant comme en amérique et puis
les on va dire la majorité des patientes
devront aller se faire soigner en
hôpital prix oui moi la question que je
me pose c'est est ce que cette situation
aurait pu être évitée si les pouvoirs
publics avaient anticipé la crise est
peut-être respecter davantage les
soignants les considérants plus
socialement financièrement est ce que ça
aurait pu être évitée skis un
responsable selon qui est responsable
alors c'est une problématique depuis
très longtemps donc on peut pas dire
c'est ce gouvernement ni le précédent
c'était dans une quinzaine d'années ou
en fait le seul critère comptable de
gestion hospitalière est prise en charge
et en fait on oriente tout en fonction
d'un objectif d' équilibre budgétaire
pour l'hôpital public or on sait que les
besoins sanitaires de la population
augmente parce que la population
vieillit parce que de nouvelles maladies
apparaissent parce que ben on veut vivre
en bonne santé et bien soigné donc il
faut accepter que l'hôpital public soit
gérée avec un certain déficit est en
fait la seule le seul élément qui est
utilisé pour équilibrer le budget
hospitalier c'est la réduction des
niches et la réduction du personnel et
ce que l'on peut regretter c'est que la
crise n'a rien fait changer c'est le
problème c'est que malgré tout ce qu'on
a répété rien n'a changé rien de rien
n'a changé juste voilé de déficit oui la
chronique de l'hôpital le président n'a
pas cessé de dire je déplore 4 milliards
ses milliards de milliards 20 milliards
pourquoi il dit pas je mets 30 milliards
sur la table on sent les milliards comme
on les communes comme on l'est trop par
terre alors il n'y a pas qu'un problème
financier bien sûr il ya un problème
d'argent il y à revaloriser les revenus
notamment des professions les moins bien
payés mais il ya ce dernier mes
activités voilà deux du travail comme
soignant à l'hôpital et il faut revoir
l'organisation la gestion
en fait l'argent qui est mis pour
financer l'hôpital public va
essentiellement pour arroser des
structures administratives en
millefeuille et en fait on crée de
nouveaux services et ça va créer de
nouveaux besoins qui n'existaient pas
sans créer des dépenses a sauté revêtent
voilà mais les soignants ne reçoivent
rien c'est vrai que les aides soignants
et soignante français vont maintenant en
suisse dans d'autres pays en allemagne
parce qu'ils y ajouter 20 ou 30 ou 40%
payer et un grenelle risation j'aimerais
ça c'est vrai layton compte à l'étranger
parce que c'est mieux payés parce que
c'est mieux organisés à l'hôpital public
un tiers des personnes qui travaillent à
l'hôpital ne voit jamais patients or le
problème c'est eux qui ont les manettes
de la décision qu'ils prennent des
décisions notamment de fermetures de
lits sans jamais avoir connaissance de
la réalité du terrain et de la pratique
médicale bertrand comment ça se passe en
belgique avait justement en belgique
c'est une problématique pour le coup que
nous n'avons pas parce qu'en belgique
nous ne pratiquons pas de numerus
clausus ce sera ce sera seulement
pratiquer à partir de 2023 donc mon
accueil énormément d'étudiants français
un peu trop même trouve-t-on par rapport
au gouvernement et il y a beaucoup fait
pas bon mais certains d'entre eux
choisissent aussi de s'installer en
belgique parce qu'ils sont ici sont
faits des amitiés mais six ont fait des
connaissances et sa pose aussi un
problème pour le coup parce qu'ils ne
reviennent pas sur les secteurs il ya un
grand débat c'est des deux personnes qui
étaient suspendues à cause de la clé du
communes qui ont refusé de seube
vacciner c'est quoi ces quinze mille
personnes soit à peu près à peu près
est-ce qu'il faut pas déjà les
réintégrer cela ben oui probablement oui
la bague loin d'aller merci probablement
moi si j'allais dire il ya quand même un
problème qu'il faut reconnaître c'est
que quand on travaille à l'hôpital il
faut accepter un certain nombre de
conditions notamment pour protéger les
autres oui aujourd'hui aulas est là pour
le coup on est il ya une urgence bien
sûr qu est-ce qu on peut joindre à lui
de poliez ce débat voilà ça sert prête
c'est un débat qui a pourri d'ailleurs
tout à fait à la france depuis
maintenant faisons pas se mentir c'est
peut-être le temps d intégrer dit voilà
il a déçu il veut pas dire que j'ai la
chance aujourd'hui que au micron on va
dire soit moins virulent et notamment
que la vaccination ne protège pas plus
que ça contre le risque de contamination
est donc effectivement on peut envisager
que ces personnes travaillent malgré
tout je reste persuadé que au départ
quand on rentre dans la profession de
soignants on doit quand même accepter un
certain nombre de devoirs et celui de
vaccination pour protéger les autres que
moi prendre en chasse par des personnes
non
le débat on sait c'est grâce à ce qui va
être fait par la nouvelle équipe en
place juste là déjà les urgences sont
saturés on en a parlé un peu dire mais
on en reparle beaucoup aujourd'hui des
gens sont en panique à cause de la
variole du singe
il ya un cas
il y avait on avait dit qu'ils avaient
trois chez moi qui toussait
doit se rassurer ou est-ce que faut qu
on va s'inquiéter alors le la variole du
singe est une maladie très rare qui est
venu d'afrique
effectivement actuellement nous
assistons à une contamination
interhumaine alors la contagiosité se
fait essentiellement par contact direct
rapprocher prolongé avec les liquides
biologiques et notamment la polo faut à
travers des dons pour la le risque voilà
de contamination par voie aérienne sur
le lieu de travail en prenant le
transport en commun est quasi nulle ou
là bas le style qui éclate et je sais ce
que je dis qu'il est bon il faut
contacter ses
professeurs il ya une biopsie cause que
train de naître parce qu'on dira donc ça
doit payer peut-être des gens qui vont
avoir un bouton ou même la varicelle qui
vont j'ai répété aux urgences parce
qu'ils pensent qu'ils ont de la variole
du singe est-ce qu'il va contribuer à
engorger encore un peu plus les urgences
oui c'est ça c'est on amplifie arrêt
c'est vrai que maintenant la population
est habituée à oak au vide on a vu un
petit peu et je rentrerai pas dans le
débat des appels en excitation c'est pas
le c'est pas le sujet effectivement on
doit on contrôle les choses on est au
début un petit peu de ce une maladie qui
peut se répandre c'est vrai qu'on
connaît maintenant faut quand même
reconnaître que pour la population le
message c'est de dire bah on est presque
on a peut-être tout le monde à 2 ans
d'expérience de savoir comment on fait
pour se protéger peut-être qu'il y aura
à nouveau une vague et on va essayer de
de ce projet la même manière c'est ça
pour répondre à votre question sur eux
est ce qu il faut faire revenir les
soignants que vous avez posé oui la
réponse est oui clairement comment il
faut les faire revenir ça va pas
résoudre le problème mais oui il faut
les faire revenir parce qu'on a besoin
je suis complètement présent qu'il nous
regarde je suis chez moi je me sens pas
bien je vais peuvent les rend pas bien
qu'est ce que je fais est-ce que je vais
me présente aux urgences et snow
j'appelle le samu dont je dois d'abord
le samu ou le samu ou votre médecin
traitant parce que c'est un très bon
vous savez les médecins traitants sont
là ils sont présents on les oublie et
très souvent nous on a aux urgences à
cette espèce de d'afflux inutile inutile
de gens qui pourraient aller voir leur
médecin traitant et qui viennent aux
urgences ils sont inquiets on comprend
on est là aussi pour les rassurer mais
le rôle du médecin traitant est
important et primordial donc il faut
aller voir son médecin traitant